Wooo we are live and I am grinning so hard my face hurts! Welcome back to The Office 360 Unfiltered. I am Alex. Halloween, 1938. Orson Welles. Martians in New Jersey. The newspapers screamed louder than the Martians. If your doorbell rings later, that was no Martian.
Ha I am already laughing. I'm Morgan. October 30, 1938. Mercury Theatre on the Air, CBS. They start like a dance band, then we interrupt this program. Grover's Mill, New Jersey. People who tuned in late missed the drama label and got the cabbage-field invasion.
They used the costume of news. Some packed cars. Papers, losing ads to radio, said look what this talking box has done. Modern research: the panic was smaller than the headlines. The Martians were fake. A lot of the stampede was extra sauce.
Ha the papers hyped the panic to dunk on radio. Welles signed off: if your doorbell rings and nobody's there, that was no Martian, it's Halloween. If your real thing is in an intro nobody hears, you are Grover's Mill with a shopping cart. Three clicks to what is actually happening.
Picture Grover's Mill, a water tower with a plaque, a kid under a table, a young man at CBS making art in the costume of urgency. At The Office 360 we put the book, the event, the donate where a thumb can hit it. You own the keys. I love this story. Come on.
Ha subject line all caps: IS THIS REAL. Email theofficetechies@gmail.com, Story Time or Shout Out. We got you covered. This hour is long because radio should take its time, except we tell you it is us talking.
We do not mock fear. We mock the buried label. Three clicks. Book. Store. Done. STUDIO50 at theoffice360.com, fifty percent off. Subscribe. Download. Tell an aunt. I am having too much fun.
Mailbox: Story Time, Shout Out, Advertise, Donate. theofficetechies@gmail.com. Pretend you tuned in late. Can you find the real thing in three taps. If the doorbell rings tonight, that was no Martian.
Landing with joy. A cabbage field, a CBS mic, papers in a costume. Put the real thing where a late arrival can hear it. Mixed yarn. Funny then useful. I'm still grinning.
I'm Morgan, he's Alex, Episode Fourteen. Martians in Grover's Mill. Email us. Listen. Download. Subscribe. If the doorbell rings, it is Halloween, we love you, we got you covered. Good night. Bye!